I definitely learned that like the the
way I act and the things I say can be
taken in the wrong way a lot of the
times when I'm just being like goofy and
messing around what happens in Vegas did
not stay in Vegas Edie has learned new
details about an incident between Zayn
Malik and Jake Paul's Saturday night as
what was the drama that unfolded on
social media the next day between palm
the former One Direction stars
girlfriend Gigi Hadid I want to bring a
lot of energy a source told et that
Malik and Paul were staying at
neighboring penthouses at Westgate Las
Vegas Resort and Casino over the weekend
after Paul invited Malik to hang out the
source said Malik to climb the
invitation its Hollywood and and
anything can happen this led to Paul
later tweeting out quote almost had to
clap up Zayn from one direction because
he's a little guy and has an attitude
and basically told me to for no reason
when I was being nice to him Zayn I know
you're reading this stop being angry cuz
you came home alone to your big hotel
room haha that's when Gigi replied to
the tweet with quote lol cuz he doesn't
care to hang with you and you're
embarrassing crew of YouTube groupies Oh
home alone with his best friends like
respectful King cuz he has me sweety
unbothered by your irrelevant ugly go to
bed you have to treat yourself Gigi was
not in Las Vegas at the time of the
incident
and Zayn has yet to comment et recently
asked the YouTube star and now boxer
about his plans for the future I don't
know what the future holds come on come
on we'll see I really don't know if you
asked me like three years ago would I be
standing here right now doing a
interview about boxing and knocking kids
out I'd be like absolutely not on my
Disney Channel and I'm a vlogger so like
I I don't know what the future holds but
you know you never know
[Music]